we talked about the background is we
talked about chess.com last episode i
tweeted about it because i was even more
people loved that tweet dude that tweet
had tons of engagement
um it was good and the the summary of
this
is that i actually we underestimated it
so chess.com gets around 200 million
monthly uniques
they have 60 million registered users
they
uh traffic has grown significantly if i
had a guest they do at least 100 million
in recurring revenue subscription
revenue
uh potentially is worth a billion
dollars super fascinating company um
go ahead what were you gonna say we were
trying to hype it and we actually were
under hyping even even though we were
trying to hype it
um and by the way the guy who started
he's like a ex stanford guy or the guy
who owns it uh you know it's two
i think stanford guys uh which is cool
like you know they didn't go the same
track probably as
95 of their classmates and they're going
to outperform
99 of them just by by doing something
really simple that the world wanted
so i started thinking about this because
we talked about it you brought it up
cool topic cool bit really cool business
it really fits the what we call the new
zealand type of business that andrew
wilkinson kind of
coined that that phrase which is it's
this independent thing
it has like a cult following it's
profitable it's simple
it's not nobody competes with it it's
like new zealand nobody's going to war
with with chess.com
uh you know the biggest competitor i
think it's called lie chess or something
like that it's basically like an open
source
free you know like kind of like
alternative and it's also doing
extremely well and those are like the
two uh but it seems like people kind of
prefer chess.com so i started thinking
okay
what's the nextchest.com what are the
others is there a whole slew of these
guys because i think that's where we
didn't talk about last time that we
should have
and so i wanted to double click in a
little bit so i started and that was
that's a really really hard
question i've been thinking about it too
i only came up with like dominoes
i looked into solitaire websites they a
lot of them crush
uh but yeah that's a hard question to
ask so i spent 10 15 minutes on it but
that was enough to tell me something
very interesting so the first one that
came to mind was because here's the
characteristics that you need
you need a game played by tens of
millions if not hundreds of millions of
people
that is not owned by a brand chess forks
checkers also works but the problem with
checkers is it's so simple that it's not
as like uh
there's not as much depth to it
therefore not as much of a like kind of
like
uh money made and passion around the
sport
uh sudoku was the second one that came
to mind so i went to sudoku.com
and sudoku.com it's just like chess.com
it's like
you you go to snoke.com and there's
already a sudoku board waiting for you
with clock going
and it's like oh play here it is you
don't need to download you don't need to
sign up you don't need to do anything
just play sudoku
i love that then they you scroll down a
little bit and you see like this
advertisement for like a mobile app a
mobile soku app
so i click that i'm like i bet this app
i bet this is an amazing distribution
for this app
app crushes so this company called easy
brand behind it
so the sudoku app that they have has 50
million downloads
the uh on just google play forget about
iphone that's just google that's just
android
um probably 100 million total lifetime
downloads
the website itself gets you know 10 to
20 million visitors a month
uh so they're getting free tr like
basically free traffic to their mobile
apps where they're able to monetize
and easy brain basically makes they're
like a mobile app developer
that makes these apps they've had over
750 million downloads lifetime of these
little simple
number game apps starting with sudoku
then like a remix of sudoku then like
another number game if you like that one
and they just cross promote them within
each other i bet this company
is crushing it they're based in europe
and that's like
i have information on on them i just
found some interesting stuff
when i googled them and went to the
website there was something amazing
about them
that immediately stuck out and and
just this quick google it i'm wrong but
it is based in cyprus any time a company
is based in cyprus
it it's like it's turns out these guys
actually
are uh from like the belarus they're
actually from this area but they're
based in cyprus
so i just googled it real quick so uh
did you know that it was they were
acquired
um three months ago no i did not know
this so that's
okay that's not the piece i have their
revenues i have their profit and i have
the uh all their user numbers and i have
can i guess
i'm going to be totally wrong but i i
like to guess by the way
a little tip always guess before you
hear any number that's how you get good
at knowing numbers
because you guess and then when you're
wrong your brain remembers that
and you you start to hone that gut
instinct okay so here's here's my guess
okay well uh how much were they what
what's their revenue i'm gonna guess
that their revenue was
400 million dollars a year okay
what's their um profit
90 million dollars a year
pretty good um all right how much were
they required for
i'm gonna guess that they're required
for 852 million dollars
okay and how many um how many
daily active users do they have across
their 15 games
i'm gonna say they have 25 million dau
okay so i didn't do you didn't do
horrible okay so
easy brain was acquired uh last this
most recent february uh they were uh
acquired for
640 million dollars in stock and
up to 120 million dollars of additional
consideration if they hit it so 640
yeah what is that that isn't that
exactly 850
no what's six uh what 640 plus 100 is
plus 25 is five seven eight so
great job you guessed 8.50 great job
you're almost there
um they their revenue is uh in 2020
revenues were 210 million dollars
okay so you were off there by half you
guessed 400 million
but their profit was 70 million you
guessed 90.
right pretty good um they've had 750
installs
over the course of their the lifetime of
all their other things
all their games they have uh 15 live
games with 12 million daily active users
you guessed
25 million okay not bad not bad um
what a company so okay so that was the
first one i thought of and by the way i
think that there's
other versions of that like you know i
don't know go look at like
you know sudokuonline.com i don't know
what's that like
you know all the things people are going
to google search if you can get the top
level domain for those that's really
interesting
um so then i started looking at some
others poker.com
so i went to poker.com and poker.com is
like
kind of like this crappy like just
describe what you're looking at when you
go to it
let me look at this but you can't this
is an actual poker right
you're not betting it's not even a as
you can't play there it's just like
reviews here's it's like an affiliate
site so it's like oh here's a place to
play poker
here's where you can go because they get
big kickbacks for basically sending a
player to pokerstars or wherever
if they deposit and so this is horrible
website
um crappy kind of like affiliate and
reviews
site dude you could do so much more with
this website like if somebody was like
dude i'm gonna
i have a if you have a mobile poker app
that's like good
i would pay like ungodly amounts of
money for poker.com i think that that's
a
and they also if you like do their
traffic search see what they get
it's nothing so they should be getting a
lot more traffic having poker.com
um okay so then there's some other ones
crossword puzzle.com
crossword.com the go to this like they
don't even like
crossroads.com or something it doesn't
even like render it's like a
there's like fun asterisks on the screen
yeah like what's going on here
because crossword is the other game
that's like sudoku it's like chess
that people played religiously and they
love we talked about how
how much the new york times makes off
their mini crossword game
the number was uh 90 million dollars in
subscription revenue from crossword
puzzles for the new york times
so so i am surprised that crossword
puzzle across the puzzles.com
crossword.com i can't believe that these
sites are not being like
leveraged so i was very surprised to see
this and
follow-up uh yeah so you go to
crosswoodpuzzle.com
it says please email suggestions to
dkw99999
yahoo.com right so i emailed the guy
so so so you see this the website is
basically like a white page with a bunch
of text
and it's basically just the very bottom
things the very bottom it says this dome
no this domain is not for sale please do
not inquire about purchasing it
all emails from anonymous are unknown
companies asking me a price will be
ignored
sorry last updated july 2007
right so i emailed this guy i was like
hey uh saw your
website um like i think it's awesome
that you're not trying to sell this
but i'm curious like why aren't you
trying to sell this and uh what's your
you know what do you want this to be why
do you believe
like why do you believe that it should
be done this way i you know i'm just
super curious like what's your thought
process so we'll see if he replies
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back